on March 25th 2015 the world learned  that Zayn Malik left the band One  Direction and from our perspective at  BuzzFeed the internet exploded with the  grief of teenagers everywhere we hit the  streets of Hollywood to find out how  people reacted oh dear you know I feel  like we all knew something like this is  gonna happen at some point A plus good  job I don't mind because he looks pretty  bored on stage all the time anyway so I  don't know I kind of understand how the  artists how they grow apart he left in  one direction was it down um well what  was his name again no you know what One  Direction is no nope has another group  three made a lot of money from one One  Direction well being a normal 22 year  old I'm 22 I don't really know what that  even means  they need to think about Zayn